the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so we have been talking a lot about sort
of the theory of things but I know you
guys want to get into the practice at
the end of class we have a lot of
plastic elements in the back that Siri
will help you guys check out some
cameras Mike's headphones tripods if you
guys want to just use your iphones for
tonight's assignment that's totally fine
as well Chris brought up a lot of really
good points of just framing
practicalities of filming I do want you
to consider though that web video breaks
a lot of these rules as well so you'll
notice that scishow doesn't do the rule
of thirds framing at all Hank green just
just fins it yes yes but he does that
very intentionally a lot of it is
because the way his videos go he'll look
to the side and a little image will pop
up so I think part of why he does that
is to leave room for some of those
visuals and Vsauce does it because he's
just super up close I'd be it's a little
weird to do a rule of thirds when you're
so up close because you don't have a
background to get rid of so much so
don't feel like you have to adhere to a
rule just because we said you know you
have to do this you have to do this
thoughtfulness is one of the values so
as long as you justify it in your
reflection or in your assignment somehow
it's totally fine so for today's
assignment in addition to the two
readings that are online and don't worry
they're pretty short and they're fun
we're going to have you guys make a
video on a basically a circus sideshow
pitch about a video that you're
eventually going to make for your final
project and it's okay if this ends up
changing it's just an exercise to get
you guys started to get you familiar
with the camera don't worry about doing
crazy camera moves or anything if all
you want to do tonight is just set up
your tripod and Mike up and deliver your
pitch that's totally fine we just want
you guys to get familiar with all the
equipment but basically it is going to
be selling an idea a topic about science
technology engineering or math that
should convince someone to want to watch
your eventual video and again it's okay
if you change the idea I do want you
guys to brainstorm three ideas in
addition
the pitch video that you make you don't
have to post them online or write them
down just have them in your head for
class tomorrow because we're going to
have some very special guest speakers
first thing tomorrow who will help you
with these pitches so to give you an
idea of the type of thing that we're
looking for again don't necessarily copy
this video exactly um what is the most
astounding fact hell what is the most
astounding fact you can share with us
about the universe the most astounding
fact the most astounding fact is the
knowledge that the atoms that comprise
life on earth the atoms that make up the
human body are traceable to the
crucibles that cooked light elements
into heavy elements in their core under
extreme temperatures and pressures these
stars the high mass ones among them went
unstable in their later years they
collapsed and then exploded scattering
their enriched guts across the galaxy
guts made of carbon nitrogen oxygen and
all the fundamental ingredients of life
itself these ingredients become part of
gas clouds that condense collapse form
the next generation of solar systems
stars with orbiting planets and those
planets now have the ingredients for
life itself so that when I look up at
the night sky and I know that yes we are
part of this universe we are in this
universe but perhaps more important than
both of those facts is that the universe
is in us when I reflect on that fact I
look up many people feel small because
they're small in the universe is big but
I feel big
because my atoms came from those stars
so obviously you don't have to do a
super dramatic thing like Neil deGrasse
Tyson did again don't feel like you have
to go home and contemplate on life's
mysteries and how you know evolution is
just this beautiful thing that happens
on earth and it's an amazing thing or
whatever but the reason why I wanted to
show you guys that video is because the
actual plastic elements of making that
were pretty straightforward pretty
simple just two cameras on a tripod
nothing too crazy but he still hopefully
manages to engage you somewhat I mean I
I personally wanted to keep watching and
keep learning about it that's partially
because of his persona which some people
find off-putting so again it's a matter
of taste but what he does here is just
sort of rattle off this theme of I think
the thesis of this whole conversation
that they have is that you take this
misconception that we all think that
were part of the universe but really the
universe and all the things that make it
up are inside of us he has this sort of
fact or nugget that he builds upon to
create this bigger narrative alright so
for science out loud George and I just
did an episode on snot and the way we
started it was one of my former
professors here Katharina ribek her lab
studies mucus and I was reading about
her in popular science because she just
got this big feature in it and one of
the facts I talked about was that your
body produces over a gallon of mucus a
day which I thought was like how does
that happen that's disgusting we think
of snot as the stuff that uses out of us
when we're sick and the stuff that we
blow into tissues and throw away but
actually it's so important that our body
makes over a gallon of it a day and that
it does more than just come out of our
nose when we're sick or when we're
crying that it's doing things like
providing moisture for our bodies which
doesn't sound like a big deal right
until you think about your body without
you kiss that your eyes would dry out
and you wouldn't be able to swallow
because your esophagus would get ripped
up every time you try to eat something
and then you think of mucus as being
more than just this sort of bodily waste
that comes out of you but really
this amazing thing that takes care of
you in a way that's so important that
you make over a gallon a day that sort
of became the pitch the the circus
sideshow step right up type of thing
that inform the rest of our video and so
that's the kind of thing that I want you
guys to be thinking about tonight and
want you guys to record now you we very
well could have had you guys just write
a pitch but I think it would be more fun
to make a video and I think it's good
for you guys to get used to using the
cameras and the plastic elements so
again don't worry about you know is my
our my camera movements good enough you
don't even have to move the camera if
you don't want to feel free to apply
around us that if you want but really
focus on clarity for this assignment so
set up the camera in such a way and set
up the lighting is in such a way that
you're very clearly visible we are going
to give you these little lavalier mic so
make sure that your audio is very clear
those are going to be the priorities for
this assignment and then make your pitch
very engaging and think of three backup
ideas just in case that sound good I had
one more example 2 we can should
hello this is Hank green and welcome to
scishow you might have noticed that I
talk a lot about how great plants are
and why shouldn't I there autotrophs
they can harness the raw untamed power
of the Sun and use it to make food for
themselves pretty impressive so why
can't animals do it well oddly enough
some of them do and in just the past few
years researchers have been discovering
animals that seem to be able to harvest
sunlight for energy take for instance
the eastern emerald alyssia a sea slug
that looks like a big floating leaf it
lives along the east coast of the United
States where it just hangs out eating a
specific kind of yellow green out so I
just wanted to show you that as an
example of the style and delivery it's
very different from Neil deGrasse Tyson
but again same concept so don't feel
like you have to be Neil deGrasse Tyson
don't feel like you have to be hankering
to talk like this and jump back and
forth between like close up and wide
screen but hopefully that gives you an
idea of what you guys need to make
tonight if you guys have any questions
I'll stick around after class and you
can always email me too so for tonight
stem pitch video series going to come
talk now about what that process exactly
looks like but basically always look at
the the online version of the syllabus
because I might tweak some things day to
day but the stuff for day one is totally
up to date right now you'll post your
stem pitch to tumblr with the hashtags
day one pitch and a hashtag of your
Kerberos ID so that's all the s utd
students you guys have an MIT ID right
okay so it's just your username and then
you'll post a daily blog and that's
going to happen every day just
reflections of what happened in class if
you want to take pictures during class
if you want to record video tomorrow
feel free to tomorrow be a great day to
record video up too soon and then there
are two readings that I'd like you guys
to annotate on annotation studio which
series going to show you right now as
well and then just bring three other
pitch ideas to class tomorrow did
everyone get the email about class time
being shifted up tomorrow so if you guys
want to show up at 12 10 that would be
good because our guest lectures are
coming at 12 15 and will end class at
315
tomorrow this is annotation studio it's
on annotation studio org and it's where
you're going to be doing your reading
assignments so what you need to do is
just go to the website click sign up or
sign in and it's a really easy
registration form first name last name
email i use my MIT email affiliation
just put MIT and a password and the most
important thing so you can get the
assignments in the first place is to
type in the class so you just need to do
20 to 19 press ENTER and it'll be blue
to like confirm that you're in it and
read and accept the Terms of Service
check that box and register and so I'll
show you what it looks like so this is
what you'll see when you sign in you
won't have any created documents but
you'll have a signed documents and the
two that we want you to read and
annotate are the first two you can't
make it on YouTube any more and this
will revolutionize education you'll
click on it and it'll bring you to the
document itself I'm so for example this
is the first one and you'll just be able
to read along and highlight it and add
in your thoughts as you go along so for
example reading it you're reading about
Hank green and how he was invited to new
TB live I was starting my own online
media conference and maybe you're
thinking well what what is that so you
can say well does anyone
and and then add some tags I don't know
what tags really do but then everyone
can see that annotation and who did it
and I'm not sure because we haven't
played around with this software too
much but you probably will be able to
comment on each other's annotations so
if for some reason someone poses a
question like this and someone knows the
answer it's VidCon then they can respond
you can add pictures you can add links
and it's just really handy because then
you can see people's idea flows as they
go through the document don't feel like
you have to spend hours
these readings are pretty bonhomie one
was posted on medium which is you know
it's not like a super dry academic
platform and the other one's a YouTube
video so just respond honestly don't
feel like they're we're expecting you
know a huge analyses that leads but you
want to see you guys creating it and
okay um the other thing I I was going to
show you guys how many of you have used
tumblr before as a platform okay so a
couple um so that's going to be our main
blog I guess for this class I've sent
you guys all an email invitation to join
the website and be able to use it this
is what the main website looks like you
should have already looked at it earlier
today and the main things are that there
are links on this top bar to the stellar
which we probably won't use annotation
studio and an ask box and so I'll beyond
the tumblr monitoring it all the time so
you can ask questions there and there's
lists of all our Kerberos is so we'll
site will organize our posts with your
MIT ID and then it's also organized so
you can look at specific assignments
like day one daily blogs and things like
that which are all sorted and dependent
on you guys tag in your posts correctly
and and there's also reference material
this bottom tab on the Left sidebar is
probably most useful for you guys and I
can't scroll down right now because they
aren't enough posts but it has things
like lists of all the assignments that
Elizabeth will post answered questions
and how to use tumblr and upload videos
on YouTube which all go through
hopefully really quickly so you guys
don't have to stay too long um for those
of you who haven't used tumblr when you
log in when you accept the invitation to
join the blog it'll look like this this
is your dashboard I have multiple
accounts and so if you have multiple
accounts you have to go up here and
choose MIT two and nine and this is
going to be exactly what your dashboard
is going to look like um so from here
you
and make different types of posts we're
probably going to use two most often a
text and a video and so for a text post
you just click text posts you can give
it a title and put something in the body
and we request that you tagged things
with specific names depending on the
assignment so Elizabeth gave examples of
what we want you to do for your daily
blogs which is day one or whatever day
it is and your MIT kerberos and so for
example if this was my daily blog for
today i would type in day one enter and
then my Kerberos which is c reilly and
it'll be different for your video that
you end up uploading to the site um and
you can include images in this you can
include other things like links if you
need be if you find that it's necessary
to your blog and click post and then you
should be able to see it right here on
your dashboard and also on the website
if you go click there okay so if you're
making a video post how many of you have
have any of you uploaded a video to
YouTube before okay this is more
familiar a way to just
there is but there's a five minute limit
for day so for tonight
just want to upload your property or
thousand tumblr that's totally fine but
eventually or some of the draft you may
need yeah so I'm just going to go
through this really briefly and youtube
com and if you have a gmail account you
have a youtube account automatically
they're linked because Google owns
everything and just click upload an
upper right hand corner select files to
upload I have an example video that I
shot this morning okay so here you have
basic information you can choose a title
a description and this is like you can
tag it with anything you want this is
the key part I think to YouTube is where
how you want to upload it so public
means anyone can search it through the
search bar through google searches it'll
be available to the public private means
you have to enter certain email
addresses and those are the people who
can access it using their gmail accounts
I like doing unlisted personally because
then if you have the link to the video
you can access it but if you don't have
the link to the video you can't see it
um it's a way that it keeps like my
draft videos like this one no one will
want to watch it eight seconds when we
talking to a phone camera and private
enough from like the rest of the world
but you can still post the link places
like the tumblr and have it be
accessible and so I like unlisted but
you can do whatever you want with your
videos and so you saw that the video
uploaded and then it takes a little time
to process and that's just YouTube and
doing things so that it can be played
that's my video now it's available the
processing is really quick because it
was eight seconds um and to upload it on
tumblr just copy the URL or the embed
code and make a video post paste it in
here and there's no thumbnail yet
because I haven't chosen one youtube set
one that's one automatically after a
couple minutes I can tag it with day one
I and my username and set a caption and
post it and it will appear on my
dashboard and on the website so this is
just like the general process under the
references tab on the tumblr there's
more detailed if you forget any of these
steps or you're having any trouble or
feel free to email me at any time and I
can help troubleshoot any steps of this
process and if you prefer vimeo you can
also upload it there and just paste in
the URL if you already have a vimeo
account there's something like that so i
know because we have to go to the last
possible minute so we'll let you go
ahead and go if you need any equipment
tonight Sarah normal stick around and
check the fountain stuff to you that you
can keep for the month if you want to
just use your iPhone tonight that's also
fine just make sure you're lit blowing
up and hear you
for tomorrow and if you have any
questions I'll sticker